To get notifications about when
a user chooses a menu
item on one of the timeline
cards you insert for them, or
if they choose the sharing
contacts that you added for
them, you need to subscribe
to get all of those
notifications.
And looks a little
bit like this.
When the user chooses any of
those menu items or the
sharing contact, we're going
to inform you through a
notification, including the
collection that was affected,
the item ID, and a little bit of
other information I'll show
you in a second.
You can think of the
flow like this.
First, your service subscribes
to notifications from Google.
Now that's going to be a post
request where you insert a
subscription into the
subscription collection.
You're going to provide a little
bit of information like
what collection you're
subscribing to.
You're going to tell us the user
token, the verify token.
And probably most importantly,
you're going to provide a
callback URL.
And this is where Google
is going to send those
notifications.
Once the subscription
is in place, this is
what's going to happen.
The user is going to
take some action.
It's going to get transmitted
to Google.
And then Google is going to
send you a notification.
Now in code, it'll look a
little bit like this.
We're going to tell you the
collection that was affected,
the specific item in that
collection that you should be
looking at, the operation, and
of course, the user token and
verify token that you
gave us previously.
Now that you have this
notification, you can of
course, do with it,
as you will.
If this is a menu item, a custom
menu item, you can
perform that action on
behalf of the user.
If this is a sharing contact,
you can then share that image
as requested by the user.